ERIC BIDELMAN: Hello,
everybody.
Thank you so much for coming
to A More Awesome Web:
Features You've Always Always,
Always Wanted.
My name is Eric Bidelman.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the
Google Chrome team.
We're goingto talk about
a lot of stuff today.
Way too many features to
really cover in-depth.
But you can follow me on Google
+, you can follow me on
Twitter, or check out some of
the articles I've written on
html5Rocks, which will discuss
some of these technologies and
APIs more in-depth.
So plenty got moreawesome.
I stood onstage last year
and gave a rundown
of really cool features.
And there's a ton of stuff
that've come since last year,
in the last six months, even
in the last three months.
Web Components is now a thing.
There's a lot of stuff
landing under this
umbrella in the browser.
You saw some at the keynote.
There's a couple sessions on
this tomorrow, including one
that I'm giving.
Really exciting, awesome
technologies under that umbrella.
WebRTC now on mobile.
Now everywhere.
DataChannel API for doing binary
streaming peer to peer
is a thing now.
Web Audio API is getting
awesome, awesome adoption
across the various
browser vendors.
So Chrome, Firefox has this
enabled in their nightlies.
Safari and iOS and mobile.
You can do real time
processing.
We'll see demos of this later
on in the browser and
JavaScript.
Request Autocomplete.
Standardizing payments on the
web is a session, I believe,
tomorrow or today on this.
Just amazing stuff.
And the list goes on
and on and on.
There's APIs for about
everything now.
But I want to focus on two
primary topic areas.
And that is CSS and
multimedia.
I think these are the two
biggest areas where we're
seeing the most changes and most
awesome stuff land in CSS
and multimedia.
So just a little convention
on this slidedeck.
You're going to see icons
for everything.
You're going to see
specification links.
There's actually one thing today
that I'm talking about
that doesn't have
a spec for it.
HTML5 Rocks article, if there's
more content on that
subject you can come back
later in the slide deck.
Old Way, the red,
old busted way.
This is a technique we have
learned how to do in the past.
And there's probably a
better way to do it.
Maybe a CSS feature has landed
that we don't need JavaScript
for anymore.
So that's what the new hotness,
the orange, means.
No JavaScript, the purple,
basically means, again CSS
stuff is starting to
take full circle.
And we don't necessarily need
JavaScript to do the things we
used to need to do.
We can offload that stuff to
CSS at the presentational
layer, where it should be.
And then that sort of leads to
this last bling, the bling of
the hash "perfmatters" tag.
This is going to be a
performance tip that you can
take advantage of.
So without further ado, let's
dive right into CSS.
If you take away anything from
this talk, it's basically that
you don't necessarily need
JavaScript for everything.
And that's really because
performance matters.
You saw the talk before me
talk about jank busting.
The more you can offload from
JavaScript, not have to set up
scroll handlers, all this stuff,
the more the browser
can optimize.
And one great example of this is
new viewport units in CSS.
So this is really great.
We have vw, vmin, vmax,
and the vmin.
So these are the
Viewport-percentage units.
So Viewport width, Viewport
height, Viewport min and max.
And unlike rems or ems, which
are based solely on the parent
container--
these are relative
to the parent--
Viewport-percentage units are
great because they're based
solely on the Viewport.
So in this sort of multi-device
responsive design
world, it's really handy to be
able to size things according
to what Viewport I'm talking
to, and my app is being
displayed on.
So one of these guys is equal to
1% of the width or height,
depending on what you're
talking about.
So one vw is 1% of the
Viewport width.
1 vh is 1% of the height.
And in the case of the vmin or
vmax, you're talking about the
minimum dimensions.
So this slide deck, for
instance, is about 1,000 by
700 pixels.
So my min would be the
height, in this case.
So 1 vmin would equal 1 vh in
the case of this viewport that
I have here.
So this is cool because we can
size things based on the
viewport, solely on the
viewport, and we don't need to
set a crazy amount of media
query breakpoints to size
things like fonts.
We can just take advantage of
these units and use them right
out of the box.
So ultimately, what this means
is you have a couple
performance gains here.
You don't have to do things like
determine the viewport
size if you're just
sizing fonts or
sizing divs or something.
You can use these units.
And you don't need to use
JavaScript to determine that
viewport size anymore.
And similarly, you don't need
to set up resize handlers.
People tend to do way too much
stuff in resize handlers.
They manipulate the DOM.
And that basically just says, OK
browser you can't optimize
scrolling or anything
of that nature.
So a quick example of this
is something like this.
I have 1,000 by 700
pixel Viewport.
And I want to set an h1 to
be 4 vw, its font size.
So what that roughly calculates
out to be is 4
times 1,000--
so viewport width--
times that 1%.
So in this case, my h1 is going
to be calculated out to
be about 40 pixels once
displayed on screen.
Similarly, I can set a div to
be a width of 15 vmin, which
means 15 times the minimum
dimension-- so in this case,
it's the height, 700 pixels,
times that 1%.
So this div's width would
be roughly 105 pixels.
Quick example of this.
So this is my current
viewport.
It's about 1,500 by 1984.
On this resolution.
So one of use case for viewport
percentage units is
things like font size.
It's really, really great.
Your fonts are always going to
look good no matter what
viewport you're in.
Now as I scale this thing down,
you'll see that my fonts
are being re-calculated based
solely on the viewport.
So those "Hello World"s are
always going to look great no
matter what my viewport
size is.
And so they're always going
to be scaled based
solely on the viewport.
So I don't have set up things
like media query break points,
define all these different
break points, for my
responsive design.
So it's pretty handy.
And support for this is actually
really, really good.
So this is sort of your current
lay of the land as far
as browser support.
You have a Safari, Firefox,
Chrome, IE has this, as well,
which is really great.
And mobile support is actually
up and coming, too.
I'm including Opera beta mobile
on here, because of
course they've moved to
Chromium recently.
So this is something you can
take advantage of today.
Really, really awesome,
especially for
responsive-type designs.
Something else we have
is intrinsic sizing.
And this is really one
of my favorites.
And a lot of people don't
know about this.
But if you combine intrinsic
sizing so
there's these new values--
and these are vendor
prefixed--
WebKit min or [INAUDIBLE].
Content, fit-content,
max-content, and
fill-available.
And so you combine something
like this with Flexbox and
it's just absolutely amazing.
It boggles your mind.
So I have display flex,
[? this is ?], of course,
vendor prefixed for this
API or this property.
My right container is
a Flexbox container.
And its content, the Hello
World, is being centered
vertically and horizontally.
Thank you, Flexbox, three
lines of CSS.
Really, really sweet.
But then I can combine it with
intrinsic sizing and do things
like, I can basically
shrink-wrap the width and
height of this parent container
down to that inner
[INAUDIBLE] content.
So I don't have to use
JavaScript to get computed
style of my inner children.
I can just set fit content to
both width and height and get
that shrink wrap effect.
I could also say Fill Available,
so take up the
entirety of your parent
container.
And so, height, 100% doesn't
ever work out like we quite
want it to, but Fill Available
does the right thing each and
every time.
You could also say
Main Content.
So in this case, shrink-wrap
yourself to be container
inside of your children.
But it's OK to wrap.
So I have a text note,
just Hello World.
That's going to wrap.
I haven't specified
for it not to.
So really, really handy.
It combines the Flexbox.
You don't have to do crazy
things in JavaScript anymore.
Support is in Firefox,
and a couple of the
mobile browsers as well.
And Chrome.
So really, really handy.
Again, height 100%, you
don't need it anymore.
You can use Fill Available.
What about CSS variables?
This is something that's sort
of been on the horizon for a
long, long time.
People have wanted proper
CSS variables to do
variables in CSS.
And we can finally
enable this.
This is an experimental feature
in Chrome that you can
enable in About Flags.
And so pre-processors have
made this really common.
GLASS, Sass, Compass.
You can set up variables
globally and then you can use
them throughout your
style sheets.
Very, very handy.
It's an obvious win
for the web.
And so we can do that now,
actually, in CSS proper.
And the way it works is that
you define a variable name.
And the only caveat is
it has to be prefixed
with this var dash.
So again, vendor prefixes
var dash, variable name,
whatever you want.
Uppercase, lowercase,
camel case.
so I'm defining a font
color to be red.
And then the way I use
this variable is
to use the var function.
So var and then the CSS
variables name.
What's really nice about this
is that, just as with CSS,
things cascade down.
That's an awesome
property of CSS.
Variables cascade down, too.
So this variable here, this font
color has been defined in
my body element, my
body selector.
And then I can use that in
any children that it
cascades down to.
Which is really handy.
It's a great property of CSS.
And that carries over to
variables, as well.
And there's also room
for fallback cases.
So if I don't have that
cascading, for some reason I'm
not getting the font color
variable in that selector I'm
using, I can use the var
function, give it the font
color variable name, and if it
doesn't exist, we'll just use
blue by default.
So that's pretty cool.
A little bit more real-world
example of this.
So I have basically defined a
couple global variables on my
root document.
This is how you define global
variables and CSS variables.
So I have a text color that
and I'm saying to yellow.
And I have a background color
that I'm defining to be pink.
But you'll notice, in my footer,
this black thing at
the bottom here is
this live demo.
And the black thing
is not pink.
It's actually black.
And that's because I've defined
a locally scoped
background color variable
to be black.
So that's sort of the local
scoping of CSS variables.
And then I'm using the text
color, which is inherited from
that global variable.
That text color yellow, up here
at the top, I can use
that because again, these rules
cascade down into children.
Very similarly, I've redefined
a new local
variable text color.
Even though it's the same as
this one that I've defined
globally, it's locally
scoped down here.
So that's why this white
span is colored
white instead of yellow.
So that's pretty awesome.
CSS proper variables.
You can experiment with this
in Chrome, again, with the
Experimental Features flag.
This is a really awesome,
great, perfect time to
highlight chromestatus.com.
A lot of stuff I'm going to
show you today is brand
spanking new.
And of course, Chrome is one of
the first browsers to see a
lot of this awesome coolness.
But we're actually trying to
track across different browser
vendors the lay of the land,
where features are in flight.
And you can visit
chromestatus.com.
It's not only Chrome features,
but what other browser vendors
are thinking.
Where specs are.
So you get a good idea for when
features are available.
What about CSS features
detection in CSS?
How cool would that be?
It's right here.
So we have, now, a new
@supports rule
that finally landed.
And we can actually do feature
detection in CSS detect
features, in our CSS features.
So this is really great.
Because we've relied
on JavaScript
libraries do this for us.
But if I wanted to I could
test the browser that the
user's using, if it
supports FlexBox.
So basically, this new
supports at-rule.
Then I give it the query,
similar to a media query.
But it's the property that
I want to test for.
So in this case, if the browser
supports FlexBox, all
the rules in this block
will then apply.
So in that case, I
know it's true.
The browser supports FlexBox.
I can set and use--
I can make the body a
FlexBox container.
So if the browser doesn't
support this new at-rule, it's
no big, nowhere.
It's just going to ignore
all the styles in there.
So that's totally cool.
There's no harm done there.
But I can do things like nodding
or anding or or-ing.
So a more complex example--
but not entirely more
complex-- is
at the bottom, here.
I can test for the negation
or the complement.
So if the browser doesn't
support FlexBox with this not,
then I can apply--
maybe I could use floats.
Or I can CSS columns.
Or I can use CSS grid
if it's available.
So really, really handy.
At the presentation level, where
you can now test CSS
features using @supports.
But similar to media queries,
there's also a
JavaScript API for that.
We do have a JavaScript
API for testing CSS
features, as well.
And that's a new property
on Windows CSS.
And there's a supports method
that you can use.
And so this is kind of cool,
because you can do things like
dynamic testing.
And so it's really important
that, for this to return true,
the browser has to, A,
support the feature,
support the CSS property.
So most browsers now
support width.
So we're cool there.
But the browser also has to
actually successfully parse
out, and this has to
be a value they can
be set to this property.
So what I mean by that is, yes,
width is supported in
most browsers.
But CSS calc a may not be.
But when I set it
to some garbage.
I use calc and, like,
ABC, or something.
That's not a parsed out value.
So the browser's actually going
to return false for that
particular call, if I'm trying
to set it up to some garbage.
And there's actually
an overload
version of this, as well.
If you don't want to give it
the simple property value
pair, you can put in your
full-on, crazy string of
features that you want to test
and featured detect.
So I can test, for example, if
the browsers support width,
setting it to this calc
value, and if the
browser supports FlexBox.
So that's how you would do
anding, nodding, and or-ing or
test for a bunch of
vendor prefixes.
So the takeaway here is that we
can reduce, possibly, once
this is supported across all the
browsers, we don't need a
library to do this for us and
do feature detection.
We can feature detect now,
natively in CSS.
So this is actually pretty
good support, as well.
Firefox Nightly has this.
Chrome and Opera have
this. @supports.
So this is a really common
thing you see
all over the web.
If you can't tell what's
going on here--
try to play this again--
If you can't tell what's going
on here, it's this thing on
the left, this Nav bar.
As I scroll this page,
this Nav bar kind of
scrolls with the page.
And at a certain point, it
stops and becomes sticky.
It sticks to that position.
So that's really great
for navigation.
And then, when I come back past
that threshold again, it
starts to be position-relative.
And this is great.
This is a really common
thing to do.
The internet is littered
with this now.
You have Google News, which
was that example
I just showed you.
Yelp, on their map results,
has this.
their map follows you as
you scroll the page.
I think TechCrunch used to have
this on their header.
So super common,
blogs do this.
Everybody's doing this.
And the way you do it
is really easy.
It's with some JavaScript.
So you find a position
fixed class that you
can apply in CSS.
Give a position fixed.
I want to tell it to stick to
zero pixels from the top.
And give it a width of 100%.
So this banner is just going to
span the entire top of the
presentation.
And what you do is you set up
a JavaScript Scroll Handler.
So you get that initial offset
of that element you want to
tell to stick at a certain
location, and then you set up
a scroll handler that basically
detects, have I
passed that initial offset?
If I have, apply that
position sticky
class, that fixed class.
And then when I come back
down, this, of course
condition won't be
true anymore.
And then you just remove
that class.
It becomes position static or
whatever it was before.
So that's super handy.
But actually, a really cool new
way to do this is to use
position sticky.
And this is actually one of the
only features I'm talking
about today that doesn't
have a spec.
It landed in WebKit.
It's super awesome,
super handy.
Because without any JavaScript,
we can have the
exact same functionality.
So I really hope it's
implemented soon in all browsers.
FYI, you can enable
this, as well, in
Chrome using About Flags.
So I can set up a class,
position sticky, vendor
prefix, WebKit sticky.
I can say, 10 pixels from the
top, that's where you're going
to do your sticking.
Totally cool, no JavaScript
whatsoever.
So if that doesn't make sense
to you, let me show you a
quick demo.
So these blue bars running
across my blog posts here are
just h tags.
And they have position
sticky on them.
And so, without any JavaScript,
I can tell them to
stick it 10 pixels from the
top as I scroll this page.
But what's really cool about
this is that, once their
parent goes off the Viewport,
off the screen, they'll also
go off the screen.
So this is a really common
UI pattern that
you're seeing now.
I think Gmail does this, the
native app, at least.
And this is really great.
Because the browser
can optimize the
snot out of this page.
Let me pump this up a little
so I can scroll way more.
It can optimize the snot out of
this page and put scrolling
on the GPU, do all kinds of
crazy cool compositing things
like the previous talk
talked about.
And I don't have to
touch JavaScript.
I don't have to sort of negate
that contract and say, I'm
going to be doing a bunch of
work in my scroll handlers.
So it's really awesome with
run new position property.
We have that functionality
without the need for
JavaScript.
So again, position sticky
enabled in Chrome.
It's in WebKit Nightly, as well,
you can play with that.
What if I'm doing crazy things
like clipping DOM elements to
crazy shapes or, like, making
interesting UIs?
One thing we've had for a long
time, actually, is the CSS
clip property.
And so, with clip, I could say
any DOM image, div, whatever
you have, clip yourself
to be a rectangle.
So that's what I'm doing here
on this image, just clipping
it to be some rectangle shape.
There's actually some really
crazy limitations with this.
First is that Clip only
supports rectangles.
I can't do anything
more complex.
I can't be circles.
I can't do polygons.
So that's pretty limiting
in and of itself.
But the more, I think,
restrictive thing is that the
element has to be position
absolute.
So if we're talking about,
again, responsive design, not
everybody's doing absolute
layouts anymore.
So super limiting, what you
can do with CSS Clip.
But what we have now is sort
of an awesome new way.
And this is Clip path.
So don't get confused.
Clip path is different
than Clip.
But this is great because it
removes the requirements of
Clip, which are that the element
doesn't have to be
position absolute anymore.
So that's great.
Can be position relative,
whatever.
So that's the first thing
it gets rid of.
And the second thing is that you
can use any basic shape in
the CSS or SVG exclusions
specifications.
So we're talking circles, we're
talking polygons, we're
talking whatever.
Whatever you want, you can Clip
DOM to that Clip path.
And you can also specify
a more complex shape.
So it doesn't have to be
just a basic shape.
It can be-- you can reference
an ID of an SVG Clip path.
And I'll show you that
in just a second.
So again, vendor prefixed, Clip
path, I can Clip any type
of DOM to whatever I want now.
In this case, I'm clipping
just a section of div.
Just some text to a circle.
And I can have a little CSS
transition as I do that.
I can use crazy CSS
animations.
And then do a star effect.
I don't know if you want
this on your website.
But it's still pretty cool
that I can do that.
And this here, the one
all the way to the
right, it's just a list.
It's a bulleted list.
And it's got a little Clip
path polygon on top.
So it's kind of a cool
tape cutter effect.
And so again, any
type of DOM--
I'm just going to go to HTML5
Rocks here, real quick.
And I have this bookmark here.
So when I do this, it's going
to add a CSS Clip path as a
circle to the entire container
of the content.
And see, it's kind of this
cool little [SINGING]
"doo doo,doo doo" James
Bond effect.
But really, I think this
is kind of cool.
We haven't been able
to do this before.
Clipping DOM to different
shapes.
Again, not just regular
You can do more complex things
like reference a
Clip path in SVG.
So I have a defined Clip
path in my SVG.
Inlined SVG to me document.
I can use Clip path and
reference a URL.
It's ID by URL here
at the top.
And so what I get for
this is crazy
modern art, or something.
I'm clipping an image with some
interesting polygons.
I don't know what's
going on there.
But again, it's not
just images.
It's any DOM.
So this is text that's being
clipped to that same
reference Clip path.
Very cool stuff.
So this one--
Safari, Firefox.
Chrome, and a couple mobile
browsers, as well.
You can play with this
today, clip-path.
All right, so that was a
crash course in CSS.
There's plenty we could cover,
as I alluded to before.
But I want to switch
to multimedia.
Because I think there's a lot
of really, really awesome
stuff coming to the browser
space [INAUDIBLE]
multimedia.
First is screen sharing.
So actually, I wrote
an article about
this on HTML5 Rocks.
I might've talked about
this a little bit last
year using a WebSocket.
You can do crazy hacks, you
can do screen sharing.
But, actually, what we have now
is the ability to proper
screen sharing with WebRTC.
So this is an extension to
the WebRTC specification.
And so, instead of getting user
media, instead of getting
camera or microphone data, I'm
going to say my mandatory--
the thing that I want
to access to--
sort of giving a Boolean--
giving it an object describing
I want a Chrome media source
and set that to screen.
So my source now is not my
camera or mic, it's the
desktop screen.
So a quick demo of that is, once
I click this button, it's
going to get user media.
It's going to create
that call.
I'm going to say, yes
I wrote this app.
I trust it And when I do,
what I get is sort of
an Inception effect.
So this is sharing, again,
not just my tab, but
it's my whole desktop.
And so you can imagine--
Google Hangouts, for instance,
uses a plug-in to this.
You can easily do something
with WebRTC now
that this is available.
Very, very cool.
Very inception-y.
What I'm not showing you here is
the more interesting thing,
which is actually sharing that
content out to other users.
So I'm just rendering that
locally to a video tag,
getting that stream.
Switch back to the
code, real quick.
So I'm getting that user
and get user media.
I'm getting this stream of data
and pumping that in, just
to a video tag.
But you could use WebRTC data
channel API, then, to transfer
that as sort of a
peer-to-peer.
You can do things like remote
desktop assistance, browse the
web together, friend and you
view different pages together.
That's all using nothing but
open web technology thanks to
WebRTC and some cool stuff
they're doing on that project.
So this one, you
can enable it.
It's still behind a flag,
at least in Chrome.
You can enable Screen Capture
Support and Get User Media.
That's in Chrome 26.
[INAUDIBLE]
Web Audio.
There's been a couple
talks last year on
the web audio API.
But we didn't have at the time
was the ability to do anything
really, really interesting
with it.
And what I mean by
that is that you
can combine the WebRTC.
Get User Media, right?
Get access to live
microphone data.
And you can combine that
with web audio.
You can do real time processing
and analyzing of
microphone input into the
laptop using nothing
but open web tech.
So this is one of my
favorites, because
it really is great.
Because it illustrates how a lot
of-- at least two of these
new APIs are talking together.
So we have Get User Media.
We have access to the
microphone data.
Vendor prefixed.
Once we get the stream, we'll
create our Web Audio context
but we won't give
it an MP3 file.
We won't give it an audio
file to play.
We'll Create Media
Stream Source.
So we'll passed that microphone
data right to the
Web Audio API.
And then we can use that API
to do real time processing,
effects, filters.
So that's really awesome.
Let me just show you a
quick demo of this.
This is a demo I did a
couple of years back.
But now--
Good afternoon.
So you can see, as I talk,
there's a canvas tag that's
doing the real time analysis
of the voice.
Get User Media is giving me
access to the microphone and
we're pumping that in to
the Web Audio API.
Very, very cool.
It allows you to do some
very interesting thing.
Not just visualize your voice.
But you can do things
like record--
So this is just a visualization
of my voice as I
talk in this second mic, here.
But using nothing but
client-side technologies--
I think it's Recorder JS--
you can record your voice, get
that data from the Web Audio
API, and then get the spectrum
data, download the wave file
of the thing I just recorded.
So really, really cool.
No servers involved
whatsoever.
It's all thanks to WebRTC
Get User Media and
the Web Audio API.
So what's even cooler
is actually--
it's not just microphone,
right?
Get User Media is for
any type of device.
I want to see if this works,
here, you guys.
Bear with.
It'll be a test of
my guitar skills.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
Let's do a cool effect,
like distortion.
That's a great guitar
distortion.
So Web Audio API--
so I don't have a
pedal up here.
This is just basically
microphone
input to a web page.
So I can play guitar
into a web page.
I can tune my guitar.
I can apply distortion
effects in real time.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
What else you can do
with this API.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
So that's interesting.
Web Audio API.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
So all I have up here is a
little USB controller that I
plugged the guitar into,
plugged that
into my USB in laptop.
And using the Web Audio API and
Get User Media, I can play
guitar and even tune.
Let's see if this
one will work.
I don't have it, Sorry
Took it off.
Very, very cool.
Really awesome examples of new
web tech working together to
do some interesting things
we could never
do on the web before.
So live input to Web Audio API
is available in Chrome.
Firefox, actually just has
a Web Audio API coming.
I believe they enabled
it by default in
their nightly build.
So I really, really hope this
comes to other browsers very
soon, implement the
Web Audio API.
I think it's super,
super awesome.
Real time processing effects
using mic input.
You can imagine sending that
across the wire using WebRTC
to do karaoke or something.
[? Audio ?] tune in the
browser, it's here.
Super, super cool.
[INAUDIBLE]
So you remember from the
keynote, you saw Google Now
sort of living on the web.
Can we do that?
With all this access to the
microphone data and these
extra devices, can we do
that in websites now.
And the answer is, sure,
we can do this.
There's a new API.
It's called the Web
Speech API.
It allows you to do speech
recognition and voice
synthesis in the web browser.
And so you can set up the speech
recognition object.
You can say, hey, I want my
results to be continuous.
I can continued to talk
in the microphone.
The user can talk.
And you can process
results for me.
I can set up in-term
results if I want.
So as the user talks, new
results are being thrown back
at me and they're
being redefined.
I get that information.
And then you set up events
for all this.
So there's error events,
result events.
In this case, on a result, all
I want to do is a rip out the
last result was filled in my
results array and then pull
out the transcript.
So this is how I get the
speech-to-text from the server
that this is talking to.
So let get this mic back up.
Testing, testing.
Testing.
OK.
I'll use good tried and true.
I can use just the
Mac's input.
Testing, testing.
So I can talk into
this application.
It's just a web app.
It's a web speech API to do
continuous dictation.
I can type an email
with no hands.
So this is great.
It's continuous playback.
You can see the results
as they come in.
Hopefully it's not going to
say anything naughty.
As they're being processed by
the server, they're coming in.
They're being redefined.
[LAUGHTER]
Apparently I just said "nutty
professor." 1910.
We're not in 1910 anymore.
But this allows for more
than just dedication.
We can do some really
interesting things with other
server-side and APIs
to talk to.
I don't know how to speak
in Spanish, but I hope
someone here does.
[COMPUTER SPEAKING SPANISH]
ERIC BIDELMAN: Italian sounds
very beautiful.
[COMPUTER SPEAKING ITALIAN]
ERIC BIDELMAN: English doesn't
sound quite as good, does it?
English doesn't sound quite
as good, does it.
So that's voice dictation
using the translate API.
But what about Star Trek?
Can we do Star Trek?
Sure we can.
Presentation.
Yes, how can I help you?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Go backward.
Go forward.
Open google.com.
Close it.
Google
"Paul Irish." [LAUGHTER]
Close it.
Make me a sandwich.
Do it yourself.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Please
make me a sandwich.
You're getting warmer
ERIC BIDELMAN: Pseudo
make me a sandwich.
You said the magic word.
How about PB&J?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
[? Quiet ?]
[? her ?]
[? up. ?]
So that's using nothing but
the Web Speech API and web
technologies.
No plug-ins whatsoever.
Very, very cool stuff.
Available in Chrome today.
We talked about a lot.
So I have about four
minutes left.
I can't cover the entire
web platform.
But we talked about feature
detection, CSS, new units,
responsive design.
CSS variables after, 15 years or
something, they're finally
like thing you could
start to play with.
Position sticky for doing
position-fixed elements that
are really easy without
JavaScript.
Live input for not only a
microphone, but different
types of devices, to
the Web Audio API.
Screen sharing.
Web Speech API.
And there's plenty, plenty
to look forward to.
Things like CSS grid layout I'm
really excited about being
able to find sort of a
grid system for your
page or your app.
Web Components.
There's two sessions on this.
Amazing, amazing stuff
you can do.
It's going to fundamentally,
I think, change the way we
develop applications.
WebRTC in mobile.
Video conferencing on a phone
using nothing but web tech.
And there's some other
cool things, too.
Blink has proposed some
interesting ideas, such as
Lazy block layout.
This is infinite scroll lists
that are really easy.
This is very hard to
do in JavaScript.
There's been a lot of smart
people on this.
They're proposing an
API to do this.
DOM attributes in JavaScript
make everyone's app faster.
So there's plenty
look forward to.
I want to point out,
if you want to
follow things in Chrome.
We're trying to track
this really, really
aggressively now.
There's these Blink Intend to
Implement emails that are sent
out to Blink Dev.
And you can follow the lay of
the land where everything is
in flight on all these new
features, if you want to stay
up to date, or six months ahead,
of where things are
implemented.
So that's really great.
Turn to HTML5 Rocks.
My team helps write
articles for that.
We try to cover some of
this new stuff so you
can learn about it.
I'm going to plug Chrome
Status again.
It's not just Chrome.
We're trying to do this for all
browser vendors and sort
of get the lay of the land.
So you can follow things.
There's bugs.
There's version numbers.
It's really, really handy.
So I really appreciate
you guys' time.
Thank you for everyone tuning
into live stream.
This presentation's going to be
up at moreawesomeweb.com.
I might not have enough time for
questions here, but feel
free to hit me up in Office
Hours or visit me on one of
those social channels, there.
Thank you, guys.
Really appreciate it.